thanks to everyone who requested this
video stick around to the end of this
video if you want to hear about how this
movie first got my attention a lot of
people have been comparing this movie to
Groundhog Day because they're both about
someone reliving the same day over and
over and there's even a montage and
Groundhog Day where Bill Murray
constantly tries to kill himself to
break the cycle which the girl in this
movie
apparently her name is tree see happy
birthday hole although who names their
kid tree is it because she's sprouting
with new life every day is it because
she needs to become one with nature it's
because the killer is constantly trying
to cut her down
ok ok I'm done but we see here trying to
kill herself and get out of the cycle
too and we see her just experimenting so
there's probably gonna be a lot of
homage to Groundhog Day like the fact
that she wakes up to the same song every
day this shots got a ton of media
references first up a poster for they
live it's a movie about these classes
that allow him to see the truth that
aliens have taken over most of the
positions of social importance this is
your speculation but maybe tree finds
something to help her see the truth
about who the killer is I don't really
know anything about adventure time so
you can leave your interpretation in the
comments I think now's a good time to
also mention that not all these things
have some deep meaning to them it could
just be that the character whose dorm
this is likes adventure time or repo-man
so I'm not gonna do all on these too
much until I've seen the movie I will
however point out that I thought this
was a Boston Bruins let go at first it
actually might be a logo for the
fictional college that they go to they
filled the university it also kind of
conflicts with this thermos that says
Loyola University
my theory is that's where they filmed it
Loyola University in New Orleans but
they rebranded it into Bayfield
University for the purposes of the plot
and here we see a flag for said Bayfield
University and take note of the baby
graphic on the left so it seems like the
killer in this movie is the school mask
or at the very least someone who has
access to the mascot costume if you're
wondering where I got the rest of the
name of the school from it's right here
on this little card and once he noticed
it the labels everywhere so it seems
they have a great sense of school pride
at this university tree lives at a
sorority house that starts with the
Greek letter Kappa but it seems to spend
most of her time with the RO Sigma Kappa
fraternity in the scene it looks like
the object that the killer breaks to
stab her with is actually a bomb I guess
the killer is a part of vapenation when
she leaves Williams Hall she's
approached by this woman wearing a tree
huggers United shirt who asked her to
stop global warming so maybe all those
jokes I was saying earlier about her
name being tree might actually be kind
of relevant perhaps the movie is an
allegory for environmental of
preservation with tree representing the
environment and her killer representing
global warming in pollution
she only has so much time to figure out
the mystery of who the killer is just as
we are running out of time to save our
environment birthday Earth Day I don't
know maybe there's something there right
after she wakes up screaming you can see
a poster of this comic woman screaming
in the background in this drowning scene
her hair is a different color and this
could be a test to see if any physical
changes carry over to the next cycle so
the original title of this film was
hacked to death which makes a lot less
sense to me than happy deathday but when
I heard the name happy deathday I was
immediately interested because one of my
favorite alien ant farm songs shares the
same title
it's also kind of funny because not more
than a month ago a movie called American
made was released which is also a Fall
Out Boy song but anyway I hope that
happy deathday the song is in the
credits or something when I see the
movie and on that note the movie will be
released this Friday and I'm gonna try
to have a video out by then so the video
should come a day early this week
remember to subscribe to Suzy's world
for new Horrors twice a week in October
ring that death bell for notifications
and I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
you